welcome to cloud on air live webinars
from Google cloud my name is Adam Levine
I'm now and I'm a product marketing
manager for cloud spanner today I'm here
to talk to you about is cloud spanner
the right database for you you can ask
questions at any time on the platform
and Googlers are on standby to answer
them so let's get started there we go so
today we've got a brief agenda we're
gonna go through a brief overview of
what cloud spanner is we'll talk a
little bit about the philosophy behind
cloud spanner and what differentiates it
from a philosophical and from a
historical context from the rest of the
relational and non-relational databases
out there on the market today
we'll also talk a bit about today what
workloads fit best and also today what
workloads fit less well and I emphasize
today because we're constantly rolling
out new features on cloud spanner to
improve the experience and provide
enhanced functionality then we'll talk
about common misconceptions with the
service common issues and finally we
will tackle some common questions before
getting to our Q&A so let's get started
so what is cloud spanner and we always
like to say great apps run on great
databases and we think class spanner is
a great database so cloud spanner is the
only enterprise grade globally
distributed and strongly consistent
database service built for the cloud
specifically to combine the benefits of
relational database structure with
non-relational database scale it's
unique in the marketplace in that it
combines transactions sequel query and
relational structure with the
scalability you typically associate with
non relational or no sequel databases
databases are part of every application
so it's very important to pick the right
database for your application so there
are a few things that are tricky about
databases that cloud spanner attempts to
solve the first is has to do with scale
most database to moose databases today
are only vertically scalable you can add
more CPU memory or disk but that
encourage downtime typically you can
also shard your database but that incurs
operational complexity and has a you
know manageability aspect that's
difficult
next operations are tricky you can have
hardware that breaks down OS and
software patches that need to be applied
there are end-of-life issues with
software that need to be managed and
accounted for and all of those also
incur downtime last you always
constantly need to tweak the performance
of the database to get the most out of
it and get everything that you want to
be able to accomplish with that unless
there's the infamous rebuilding of
indexes which is a dreaded task by a lot
of DBAs also it could incur downtime
replication is another area that's
tricky making sure all copies of the
data are up-to-date across different
replicas providing read-only replicas
for enhanced effort reducing latency and
increasing the throughput of your
application as well as performing during
disaster recovery using replication all
those are very tricky things to get
right keeping them in sync is
non-trivial and there's always a finite
replication delay when you try to do
this on your own
last transactions particularly around
readwrite transactions are hard to do
when you are sharding and replicating
your database ensuring strong
consistency makes a developer's life
much simpler because they can rely on
strong consistency instead of having to
write in application logic to deal with
the constraints around eventual
constraint consistency so all four of
these activities make databases tricky
today cloud spanner is the first and
only relational database that's globally
consistent horizontally scalable and
fully managed so you don't have to
compromise you don't have to make
trade-offs to get all of the all of
these
aspects around performance scale sequel
and manageability with cloud spanner you
enjoy all the traditional benefits of a
sequel database transactions high
availability schema changes without time
time and sequel queries but unlike many
relational databases cloud spanner
scales horizontally from 1000 - from 1
to thousands of service servers an
arbitrarily large number with fully
automatic data replication and server
redundancy cloud spanner delivers up to
five nines of availability in multi
region instances and four nines of
availability in regional instances in
fact Google's internal spanner instance
has been handling millions of queries
per second from many Google services for
years we've been running various
services on them on spanner for many
many years so it's battle tested and
tried and true cloud spanner combines
relational semantics found in
traditional relational databases with
horizontal scale associated with
non-relational databases cloud spanner
is the no compromise database you can
have your cake and eat it too many other
databases out there today approximate
aspects of what cloud spanner enables
but they don't quite fully get there and
you see in the market today lots of
existing database services adding on
additional features to try to
approximate what clouds been our
achieves but cloud spanner solves these
fundamentally challenging problems at
the core so with the these challenges
are not being addressed as add-ons but
as something that's fundamental to what
the database does cloud spanner has
relational semantics with schemas
enforced data types strong consistency
and acid transactions across rows tables
regions sequel query using ANSI 2011
sequel with extensions you also get all
this with horizontal scales you can
scale to arbitrary large database sizes
because so combining relational
semantics and horizontal scale all in
one easy-to-use database so let's take a
step back a little bit let's talk a
little bit about the philosophy of cloud
spanner and it's super important to
understand the philosophy
a fee of cloud spanner in order to
understand the way it works and that
will help determine if cloud spanner is
the right database for your application
so first and foremost with cloud spanner
the application is control is in control
of its database the database is there to
store the data and to ensure that data
is strongly consistent and replicated
and always available in traditional
relational databases the database was in
control of the data enforcing value
constraints doing data verification with
triggers and stored procs and and very
fine-grain Ackles with cloud spanner
that application all of that application
logic is pushed into the application and
you have to consider that when moving
from one database to cloud spanner
so with cloud spanner the application
determines what's valid such as you know
not null constraints and unique indexes
being controlled with spanner and then
there is no real business logic within
the database layer so the application
has to control that and use cloud
spanner for what it is built for which
is storing data so let's dive into the
implications of this philosophy and what
it means for an application to be in
control and the database to do things
that databases should be doing
so what workloads fit best with cloud
spanner and first and foremost sharded
relational database systems such as
sharded my sequel anytime where you have
a sharded relational database that is
difficult to maintain that is becoming
unwieldy that's a perfect fit for moving
to cloud spanner because cloud spanner
gives you that scale and the familiar
relational semantics and that sequel
query ability but it removes all of the
over management overhead all of the
operational headaches associated with
sharded my sequel and manually charting
and it's
as sort of a natural progression and
even in the sort of original reasons why
cloud spanner was built was because
Google was using a sharded my sequel
database and realized that it was just
too difficult to continue to maintain
that so that was one of the primary
drivers for for building spanner in the
first place the second reason and the
second workload that fits really well
with cloud spanner is anytime you have
scalable relational data and you're
running out of headroom in your
relational database and you're
considering moving towards a no sequel
database or a non-relational store and
when you move to a non relational
database you often have to give up you
often have to make a compromise you
often have to make a trade-off and
whether that's in terms of consistency
manageability transactions or any number
of things people are willing to make
that trade-off often in order to get
scale as their application grows but
with cloud spanner you don't have to
make that trade-off you can get the
scale you need as well as the familiar
relational semantics last manageability
and h.a if you just want to get out of
the business of managing your databases
cloud spanner is a great fit it's a very
easy to use system particularly for how
complicated it is under the hood we
abstract away all of the operations of
the database so there's no such thing as
planned downtime with cloud spanner
everything is an online operation all
patching and upgrades are online index
rebuilds are online adding an index
schema changes all of that is an online
operation and so you can get out of the
business of managing same is true for
providing high availability cloudspinner
provides that out of the box we
replicate your data multiple ways
depending on the configuration that you
choose and create when you set up your
cloud spinner instance but we handle
that all for you so you don't have to
worry about it and we provide SLA high
availability SLA is to guarantee that
your
we'll always be there next is
multi-region with cloud spanner you can
write once and have the database
automatically replicate your data to
multiple regions whether that's for high
availability or for reducing read
latency that depends on the needs of
your application we have multiple multi
region configurations from you to choose
from depending on the needs of your
application and we're always add we're
always adding new ones based on customer
demand after saying that though most
customers still use regional instances
today because you get the high
availability we backup your we replicate
your data to multiple zones within a
given region and most customers are
using regional instances today but it's
nice to know that multi region instances
are available should you need them so
let's take a look at where cloud spanner
is available so as I mentioned most
commonly used our regional
configurations we have cloud span are
available in many many GCP regions
across the globe and we're always
rolling out new regions so for instance
just last week with the launch of the
new Hongkong region cloud spanner was
available in Hong Kong and we'll be
announcing new regions again in the new
future in the near future where cloud
spanner is available and so wherever
your application is there's a cloud
spanner instance available to you nearby
regional configurations are what the
majority of customers use they put their
application workload in the same region
as the spanner instance to reduce
latency and then that spread your data
is spread over several zones within the
region so that the app has the same
ability as the database and that's
important to remember the database is
just one particular part of your
application in one place where you know
availability is but if your app goes
down and the database is still there
then users still can't use your
application so as I mentioned regional
instances have four nines SLA and coming
soon
we'll be adding new regions so we have a
number of multi region configurations
depending on where your application
users are and what your needs are so
this first one name three it's called is
multi region configuration on the east
coast of the United States in North
Virginia and South Carolina and multi
region instances are a bit more
expensive than regional instances but
you do get an extra nine of availability
so with all these multi region
configurations that I'll go through you
get five nines of availability that's
less than five minutes of downtime per
year which is pretty extraordinary
considering what it takes to get that
level of high availability with an
on-premises databases and to guarantee
that level of high availability so this
is the first multi region configuration
we also have another North America
configuration that has two readwrite
regions one in South Carolina one in
Iowa and then it also has two read-only
regions one in Oregon and one in our new
la region and so this configuration is
great for data that you need replicated
across the US for an app that is used
predominantly in North America but
because of the Google Network it could
also serve data at pretty fast speeds
across any ocean and as your data is
replicated on both sides of the country
both sides of the u.s. it has you know
sort of closer proximity to cables
crossing the Pacific as well as the
Atlantic there's also a multi region
configuration in Europe with read/write
replicas in the Netherlands and Belgium
for European centric workloads and this
provides five nines of availability
while still keeping your data in Europe
so it's a great option for customers
based out of Europe and last is a global
configuration so this
figuration has the readwrite regions
within the United States in Iowa and
Oklahoma and then read-only regions in
Europe and Asia
so for truly global applications this
configuration is perfect for you now
it's really interesting to think about
whether you need a multi region
configuration or you just need multiple
regional configurations and that really
depends on the needs of your application
and what you're trying to accomplish
whether you're trying to have your data
replicated around the world so you can
have very low latency data access across
the world or if you can sort of separate
your users out and have each country
sort of operate separately and then you
can use multiple regional instances as
opposed to a global configuration or
multi reaching configuration so the
choice is up to you but cloud spanner is
here to support so let's talk a little
bit about when cloud spanner fits left
less well and the next few slides might
seem negative you know I'm a marketer
but this is not supposed to be negative
I you know I really want to be honest
with you all today and and provide
insight into where cloud spanner excels
today and where it may require a little
bit more work to be able to use because
cloud spanner provides relational
semantics and scale it seems like the
perfect solution and it is for many
workloads but there are a few instances
where it may require a bit more work and
a bit more thought in your part so the
first is lift and shift and this really
comes down to the fact that cloud
spanner the philosophy of cloud spanner
it's not a compatible database that you
can't just take a my sequel application
and/or database and lift it up and put
it on cloud spanner it doesn't have
compatibility
it doesn't do some of the things that my
sequal does and for some traditional
databases that may have 30 years of
features that have been added over time
cloud spanner doesn't have a lot of
those features because of the philosophy
philosophical differences between cloud
spanner and traditional relational
databases so customers who have a lot of
business logic in their database using
triggers stored procedures have a hard
time sort of moving to cloud spanner
sometimes because they have to take that
business logic and move it back into the
application the application is in charge
of business logic the application is in
charge of knowing when something should
happen the database is there to store
data and make sure it's available and
make sure that it's replicated so clouds
manner does not have sugar triggers and
stored procedures it's not necessarily a
blocker though some customers see the
benefit of rewriting their code to
optimize it for the cloud and so it's
sometimes a great opportunity to
re-examine some of the the legacy code
that may exist in your codebase and then
sort of modernize it for a cloud design
point the next is compatibility
customers who want rapid lift and shift
you know migrating to cloud spanner may
not be sort of a trivial task when you
just want to flip something up to the
cloud and so what we see a lot of the
times is folks moving to something like
cloud sequel Postgres first and then
modernizing over time to get to cloud
spanner this is certainly easier today
with the enhancements that have been
made around DML and and an upgraded JDBC
driver but there you know all of the
tools and all of the other ecosystem
things that you might
sort of rely on you need to take a look
at that and see what you rely on and and
what your constraints are when moving to
cloud spanner and we're always adding
new drivers and new ORM tools and new
you know the rest of the ecosystem but
just take a look at see what's available
today and see what's on the roadmap for
tomorrow and see if there's a path
that's compatible with what you need and
the last thing I want to mention is apps
that need super low latency cloud
spanner isn't the right choice for you
that's not to say that cloud spanner
isn't fast it's very fast but when
you're talking about microsecond
nanosecond you know very low
single-digit millisecond latency
cloudspinner probably isn't the right
tool for that job other services like
cloud BigTable or even in memory
services like cloud memory store for
Redis are probably the thing you want to
look at if you need you know ultra low
latency clouds manner high provides low
latency but not at that you know you
know very low level you can also get
very sustained and consistent levels of
latency with cloud spanner as you scale
up which is one of the nice features
that customers love about it as they add
more nodes to their instance and their
configuration there they see the latency
sort of keep up and not not escalate as
there the load on their database grows
so those are some of the key areas where
cloud spinner fits less well let's talk
about some of the common misconceptions
around cloud spanner and this is really
where we get into the questions that get
asked around cloud spanner a lot and
it's funny because there are when people
start looking at cloud spanner most
people have the same common set of
questions and I want to address those
today the first is that yes this is
fully managed there is no software
patching no upgrades no downtime no
index rebuilds no reach
guarding and you can dynamically scale
up and down in fact it only takes four
clicks to create a cloud spanner
instance you just go into the GCP
console and you create your spanner
instance you give it a name you pick how
many nodes you want you pick what
configuration type you want whether
that's regional and in what region and
also or if you want a multi region
instance and then you click create and
in a matter of seconds you have a fully
managed you know fully replicated you
know scalable database and what's really
nice about it is as your application
needs grow you can just go back into the
console or you can also do it
programmatically as well and increase or
decrease the size of your instance you
can just go in and click you know one
one two however many times you need and
get more throughput for your instance
and in a matter of seconds you have
additional throughput it sometimes takes
a couple minutes for cloud spanner to
repartition and balance out your data
but this is something that the database
is always doing on the back end anyways
re partitioning restarting you know
electing new leaders in this within the
system on the back end is something that
is constantly having it's constantly
going on within this system it's not a
failure event that's not a scale event
this is just something that the database
is always doing so as you add more notes
it just says hey I've got more more
nodes to add to my cloud spanner
instance and it bounces the data out and
that you know takes a couple of minutes
but compare that to what it's like
increasing capacity on an on-premise
database where you have to order
capacity wait for it to arrive take it
out of the box plug it in set it up I
mean we're talking months cloud spanner
gives you this in minutes and it's it's
it's really a a different type of
management experience and through
customers where
you know if for operators who want to be
able to you know control every single
aspect of the database and know where
every block of data is stored on disk
cloud spanner is fully managed so you're
not going to get that level of
granularity of control so it does
require a bit of a shift in thinking
around what it is that you spend your
time on when it comes to managing the
database but as I'll get to in the next
couple slides there's still a lot to
think about and a lot to plan for and
using cloud spanner the next common
misconception is around strong
consistency and this is really a
philosophical aspect of clouds manner as
well and this comes to improving the
developer experience being able to rely
on strong consistency is super important
and super powerful to a developer with a
lot of sharded databases with a lot of
scale out databases particularly those
that cover a wide geographic area they
have to rely on adventure those
databases use something called a ventral
consistency or maybe there are multiple
flavors of consistency but not there
aren't any that offers strong
consistency across regions like cloud
spanner and when you have to reason over
eventual consistency you have to build
in complicated checks into your
application code to say hey is this a
stronger hey is this an eventual read is
this the latest of today can I trust
what this is this thing is with cloud
spanner everything is a strongly
consistent read you can do bounded stale
reads if you need to improve latency but
it's still your data is still strongly
consistent you're never gonna get
anything that's out of order
you might just if your application is
okay with it you might just get
something that's a few seconds older but
not out of order and so this is really
sort of an enhanced version of
on consistency called external
consistency where we talk about external
as being able to look at an external
wall clock and see what time something
happened within the database and that's
really the foundation of how cloud
spanner works it relies on a combination
of software and hardware to enable this
low latency synchronous replication so
data is always available on commit and
you and rites happen at super low
latency once a quorum of all regions
within an instance have accepted the
right and so this provides a true asset
database that spans multiple regions or
multiple zones within a region offering
strong consistency and this is possible
through the high speed network that
Google has built out as well as relying
on a fully optimized stack in turn
including a true time which you may have
heard about which is uses atomic clocks
and GPS satellites to provide very very
accurate and pinpoint time so different
replicas that span a geographic a wide
geographic area can still take the same
time and reduce the uncertainty around
when something happens so let's talk
about a couple common issues that
customers face when moving to cloud
spanner and the first Israel around key
choice your key choice is super
important sequential or x time stamp
based keys can cause hot spotting which
can impede your performance so you want
to be very careful around that random
you IDs or hashes distribute the data
better some sort of composite around
randomly IDs work well too so that's
very important to think through what
schema you're gonna choose when in your
schema design when moving to cloud
spanner and that's a bit of a shift in
thinking from traditional relational
databases next as I mentioned before
lack of triggers store retrieved proceed
check constraints mean that you have to
move that logic into the application so
not no constraints exist and keys are
unique and unique can't column values
via indexes but you need to think
through how you get all of that
application logic out and put that in
your application and use the database
for storing data a couple common issues
also to just mention foreign key
constraints and on delete cascade only
exists with parent-child interleave
tables so Claude spanner has a
interesting concept that's similar to
like a pre join called interleaved
tables which you know we don't have time
to get into in detail today but it
allows you to signal to the system that
you want data physically stored next to
each other or physically stored on the
same the same split within the database
and that allows for commonly for data
that's commonly accessed together to be
accessed faster than it would if it was
stored on a different split and that's
just an optimization but something to
think through as you're designing your
cloud spanner schema more common issues
indexes are table twos tables - so you
have the same constraints for index keys
as you do for you know your primary key
where you don't want to just use a
incrementing value because that will
lead to hot spotting next your primary
key is the row ID so it uniquely
identifies the row and it's used to
determine where the row is in storage
and that's really why hot spotting
happens with cloud spanner because we
group rows that are next to each other
together and store them on the same
split to allow for faster access and if
you're always writing you know
sequentially you're always going to be
writing to the same note as opposed to
allowing the system to distribute that
load evenly across multiple nodes last
backup and disaster recovery we're
always improving in this area and the
system obviously takes system backups
and we handle high availability and we
have an old replication for you but
terms of managed backup tools that you
might be familiar with in your existing
database where we're working on that
still today there's managed export and
import we take one hour of historical
data snapshots which you could go back
to and we have a system manage backup
service coming very soon but it's a
little bit different than how you what
you might be expecting compared to
on-premise today so it's just something
to think about
but obviously not an impediment usage so
some common questions that we always get
around cloud spanner
what's the replication to delay you know
you're moving data around the world
around the country around the region
like this thing obviously ha has to be
slow and effectively there is no delay
you know as soon as the transaction
commits reads from the replicas we'll
have the latest data and we guarantee
that because before you get the hack
back or about you're right that data has
committed to a quorum of the replicas so
every replica knows what is the latest
and if it has the latest data so you're
guaranteed not to get old or stale data
unless you want it as I mentioned you
can get bounded still reads in which
case you're okay with slightly out of
date data in practicality you know it's
a few milliseconds what the replication
delay is and that's just seen as query
latency from the application the other
question that we often get is when to
use cloud spanner versus cloud sequel
versus cloud BigTable and this really
comes down to what do you want out of it
out of your database if you want to
manage transactional query Bowl
infinitely scalable no downtime database
use quad spanner if you need something
that's transactional quería Bowl you
some you can tolerate occasional
maintenance and downtime but you're
willing to sacrifice that for
compatibility with my sequel and
Postgres and you're okay with you know
limited scalability limited Headroom
cloud sequel is perfect
that and if you need super low latency
but and you're willing to trade off a
query ability cloud BigTable is the
database or the data store for you and
choosing between the three of those
really comes down to what are the unique
needs of your application and what you
need to be able to accomplish with your
database some additional questions this
one always comes up why is cloud scanner
so expensive now and really it's it's
sort of that initial sticker shock that
but once you start to think through it
and compare cloud spanner to other
databases it's really not so expensive
particularly compared to on-premises
and you have to think about what you're
getting when you buy cloud spanner for
the minimum production configuration
you're getting six terabytes of storage
you're getting up to 30,000 QPS of reads
up to 6,000 QPS of writes each note is
replicated three times so in a three
node cluster your data is spread across
nine nodes and in three different zones
and it's fully managed fully backed up
fully replicated for you so you're
getting a lot that's all baked into that
price it's just not broken out in terms
of buying a core thing and then adding
on additional functionality it's all
it's all just one price next question is
is cloud spanner
sequel compliant yes its ANSI 2011 with
extensions we support insert update
delete select sequel statements as it's
very familiar to folks moving from
traditional relational databases to
cloud spanner and then after saying all
of these things people often ask is
cloud spanner really relational yes it
is it's provides strong consistency
strongly-typed schemas sequel queries
with inner outer joins and so it really
is a scalable relational database there
are some philosophical differences at
its core that changed the way that you
have to think through using the database
but
it's still a relational database it's
still scalable it's still sequel all the
stuff that's familiar and you're used to
and it's part of a broader portfolio of
fully managed data services so from
always having a managed in-memory data
service for Redis and cloud memory store
to having non-relational databases in
cloud datastore cloud fire store for
mobile application mobile web and IOT
application development to cloud
BigTable which is a wide column database
service for super low latency data
access and then on the relational side
we have cloud sequel which has managed
my sequel and Postgres and cloud spanner
which is you know what we've been
talking about today in terms of a
scalable relational database and then
for object store we have cloud storage
and for data warehousing we have
bigquery which is our enterprise data
warehouse offering so I hope you enjoyed
this talk I hope it was helpful in terms
of thinking through how cloud spanner it
might be the right tool for your
application the right database for your
application I hope this thought through
some of the questions that you thought
this was helpful think through some of
the questions you might have and now
please stay tuned for live here Nick
we'll be back in less than a minute
thank you
you
welcome back so we've got some questions
from the audience that we're going to
answer here so the first one is what's
so special about strong consistency and
really this comes down to making
developers lives easier if they can
assume strong consistency they can
assume that every read after a write is
the latest and greatest data and that
just makes thing that makes life simpler
there's a lot that's been published on
even how eventual consistency can lead
to bugs and security holes but you know
that's that's sort of on the extreme end
but at its core strong consistency is
just you know a nice nice aspect to have
for developers developers that rely on
eventual consistency if they're building
multiple applications they have to solve
the problem of dealing with eventual
consistency for every application
whereas cloud spanner solves that
problem in the database so cloud spinner
does what databases do really well in
terms of storing data and providing the
the latest and greatest version back to
application so the next question is why
doesn't cloud spanner have all the
features I'm used to having in my
on-prem database and so a lot of on-prem
databases have been around for 30 or 40
years so they've had there's been plenty
of time lots of customer feedback in
terms of what features they want also
philosophically these databases are a
little bit different these databases
support business logic in the database
the database is in control with cloud
spanner the application is in control
and cloud spanner is just there to store
the data and read/write the data we're
you know based on customer feedback and
customer input we are always adding new
features to cloud spanner so if you have
a feature that you really need please
let us know we
we want to know what you guys need
particularly as you modernize your
applications move them to the cloud and
use all of all of what the cloud has
tall for today next question is how can
I try out cloud spanner the easy answer
there is to spin up a Google cloud free
trial and take a look at cloud spanner
you know while you know you can go look
at the at the pricing sheet and said oh
well you know I'm not gonna be able to
use anything in production you're the
free trial is more than enough to go in
and play with cloud spanner and start
playing around cloudspinners billed
hourly so you know just because you go
in and create an instance does it mean
that you're gonna get billed for a
month's worth of usage next question is
when do you use BigTable vs. cloud
spanner I touch on this a little bit but
really it boils down to BigTable is for
super high throughput low latency reads
and writes and that's great for IOT data
for streaming data time series data for
for using as the backend store for for
graph stores BigTable makes a lot of
sense there it doesn't have its scalable
in the same way spanner is but when it
replicates it's eventually consistent
there's a replication across zones is
eventually consistent as well as it
doesn't have the sophisticated query
ability that cloud spanner does so
everything in BigTable is a point lookup
or a table scan whereas cloud spanner
gives you the the sequel query ability
you'd expect out of a relational
database that being said though there
are a number of use cases where BigTable
is the right choice and it mostly has to
do with latency and and super high
throughput where you just need you know
that blazing fast speed and so the last
question question here is I have a
custom application that runs on legacy
databases can a migrated to spanner is
spanner full-fledged our DMS and the
short answer is yes
you can migrate it's not going to be
just a straight lift and shift there in
moving to cloud spanner you're going to
have to think through what are the
aspects in your database what's the
business logic that's in your database
what are the queries you have in your
database you'll have to monetize that a
little bit but if you do have just a
simple application and something that
has simple usage of a database there's
no reason why that wouldn't just move to
cloud spanner and then you can optimize
over time but we do see a lot of
customers that either you know think
through and take the time to modernize
as they move to cloud spanner or they
lift and shift to cloud sequel as a
first step to get the data into Google
cloud and then take time and take the
opportunity to move to cloud spanner as
their means grow so those are all the
questions I have please stay tuned for
the next session which is on how to
enhance security and privacy of your
container infrastructure thank you so
much for joining today
[Music]
you